foreign
what's up Sadie
hello how are we doing
I'm good how are you we are rocking on
to the Breaking Dawn Sadie having a
party oh yeah
oh yeah what's up
um so first of all thank you for taking
my call of course um I've had a pretty
hearty year
um and your podcast and your show has I
watch every day and it's giving me some
awesome tips for dealing with my
childhood trauma and some things I
struggle with
um and so I had a question for you that
I think you can help me with well first
of all I'm sorry I've had a bum year and
the cool thing is we got nine more
months to go so we can turn this ship
around right and uh thanks for being
with us man it means it means the world
to me thank you so let's let's figure it
out let's do it what's up
okay so my question is
my husband doesn't believe in mental
illness
um I have been clinically diagnosed with
OCD and ADHD welcome to the gang yeah I
know that I'm unmedicated for so
um yeah trying to navigate that I was
diagnosed as an adult after I have my
children
um and I've also suffered through bouts
of depression
um how do I get him to understand these
are very real for me and affect my
day-to-day life
um even if I'm in agreement that I don't
not that I don't believe in mental
illness I don't think I'm broken
um a little bit of background my Asus
score is a nine one oh yeah nine
a nine
yes sir God Almighty my husband is a
zero
um and we've been together since we were
15 and 17.
so I think there's been some times for
him where he's seen me as what he would
think in his mind is quote unquote
normal
um and now I'm 29 and a lot of this
stuff is resurfacing
um part of my bummy year is I lost my
dad unexpectedly last June I'm so sorry
um he had been an addict my entire life
and got clean 10 years ago
went back to college
um got a degree in addictions counseling
started a program here in our hometown
where he helped hundreds of families
um and he passed away in June from a
accidental fentanyl poisoning
oh man so did he have a relapse
um I'm yes and at first it's been
been sort of trudging
the first and now it's been about nine
months and it's saying yeah we're
looking back at all this and
he had relapsed and it's heartbreaking
because
I think he felt like he was the strong
person leading everybody and he's died
and what's happened is a lot of my own
trauma has resurfaced and affected me
but I'm also seeing a lot of
him and me yeah
and uh how old are your kids
they are two and four yeah
I would expect and I don't say this to
freak you out I say it's just just just
to be ready
um as your body begins to remember those
moments as your kids hit those
Milestones expect your body to try to
solve that again because it missed out
the first time around is going to try to
solve it again now that you're you're
taller and you have bigger muscles right
yep yep and that's what I tell my
husband is Dr John always says like the
body doesn't forget yeah yeah especially
not with the nine
um yeah
there's so so much here
um
oh you could do probably like an entire
series just in my life well here's the
thing so
um your husband actually sounds like a
knight he's a nice guy
he's amazing okay and he's an idiot and
those two things can be true at the same
time right okay
and tell him that I said that that's
fine tell him he sounds wonderful and
he's a [__] the second thing is he
would agree yeah right the second thing
is two things can be true at the same
time
um
that your dad
was absolutely in no shape when we're
fashioned the dead that he should have
been for you
and
that guy loved you through the the foggy
lens of addiction
yeah right he loved his baby girl
yeah and that's something that I didn't
realize until he passed away that's
right because there's unresolved
stuff there that's right and you'll
never be able to have the conversations
that's right you can't you can't yes
and so one of the devastating moments of
grief is being able to have those
conversations with The Ether
yeah and even if you'd had him you know
the Sadie he wouldn't have heard him
right yeah and so all that to say is
both of those things are true at the
same time here's something else that's
true
OCD and ADHD are very very real
and yeah
they can't be the excuse by which our
life the the lives of those who love us
interact with us that we've chosen to be
in relationship with have to suffer
both of those are true also okay so what
you're you're holding this Paradox and
it's it's messy and those who love
people who struggle with addiction those
who struggle with mental health
challenges those who are married to
amazing people whose lives were pretty
greased
um moving forward pretty pretty
straightforward lives
um the Paradox the two sides of that
barbell are just the weight is really
heavy
yeah is that fair
yes and I want to put it down yeah there
you go there you go okay
um I'm gonna walk through a couple of
things because you and I like um back
when I was in the middle of all this
those were my two two of my main
clinical stamps okay ADHD and OCD okay
um
and interestingly I never my anxiety was
always an outflow of those things okay
yes um
if you use and I
I I'm speaking to you and I'm also
talking to the audience okay so you may
say that's not me at all this is what
I'm saying but I'm speaking generally if
you use ADHD and OCD as excuses for not
being a present or direct or connected
spouse
your husband's gonna have to go to war
with ADHD and OCD
yeah because some some people
um when things are uncomfortable or
they're ugly or they're not the way they
should be
they go to war with reality
it's how a million people plus died of
covid and you still have people saying
that's not real that that was that was
the response sideways of course was
there all the nonsense with vaccines and
mass yes
oh is covet super real yes
right and sure a whole swath of our
country didn't want to believe that so
they just went to war with reality
yeah if I'm married to someone who I
love deeply and I've been with her for
half of her life or more and then she
tells me there's this thing
that keeps her from being on time
from paying attention to me to being
able to put her phone down to staying
connected to want to be intimate I have
to go to war against those things
because I can't go to Oregon's her
because I love her too much
and so it does injustice to ADHD and OCD
it does injustice to the marriage it
doesn't Justice to the people you love
and it doesn't Justice to you to use
those things as excuses and so you've
heard me say this a lot those are simply
a context not an excuse
sure they're just the like I wear
sunglasses and the world looks dark it's
not dark the Sun's shining I meant I it
just looks darker to me so I have to be
okay with that I have to just know
that's just the way I see the world and
experience the world
the second thing is when you have OCD
and ADHD especially we often want to
make a show of it
okay so here's an example in my house I
sat I checked the locks three or four
times before I go to bed
I could make a big announcement I have
for 30 years I have forever
I could make a huge announcement
well my OCD is making me get up and go
to I just don't I just say he'll be
right back
or I just say I'm gonna run to the
basement real quick
and I'm pretty sure my wife knows what
I'm doing but maybe she has no idea and
maybe after all these issues and no I'm
not making an announcement about it I'm
just going along with the things that I
got going on
um when my mind is looping and racing
and I'm having the same conversation the
same fight the same loop-de-loopy
loop-de-loop and I know you know what
I'm talking about with that
um oh yeah
I don't announce to the house my OCD is
real bad right now
I have taken ownership of it to say
um I'm choosing to engage in these
strange one-sided conversations that I
would never have in real life right and
and so I'm trying to communicate
ownership but I don't go around the
house making proclamations about these
things
um
also it's my responsibility it's our
responsibility it's your responsibility
whether therapy exercise and nutrition
whether medication it's our
responsibility to do the work way
Upstream so that the people we love and
who interact with us aren't left trying
to hold together The Frayed edges of
the tapestry of our relationship
yeah does that make sense
yes so when you have OCD and ADHD what
are what are a couple of things that
drive your husband bananas
um
but I would say since my dad passed I
would describe it as like a flare-up
like the anxiety so he wants me to come
to him and just say like
tell me when you're feeling something
because I was raised in the house where
I wasn't hurt so I had internalized a
lot
um I'm at an age and a point in my
marriage we've been married almost seven
years
where
I it's like I'm it's like I my dad died
and I didn't realize all these things
before
that are not flaws in me necessarily but
just
it's things like hiding like when I was
little I would physically hide a lot yep
um and now I've tried to describe to my
husband he's trying to figure out like
what's going what's going on with you or
why are you doing this and I'm trying to
explain to him like I feel like
I'm hiding
in different ways
um so what's a way so you know that you
you know that you you're someone who
Retreats what is a way that you and him
that you can stop keeping secrets for
someone with an Aces score of nine
Secrets will kill you
and see Secrets will and I'm thinking
Secrets secret actions secret crushes
secret thoughts secret hey I had two
more drinks last night than you know
about like Secrets across the board
um
and he's gonna feel like and again in
the same way that I would tell him if he
was on the phone don't tell her how to
feel
right he's gonna feel like
he is not enough of a husband he's not
trustworthy enough he's not safe enough
for his wife to feel safe with him
yes and he's mainly why I call then
because he is so amazing and he takes on
the brunt of that and it's me trying to
explain to him not using it as an excuse
necessarily but I want to undo these
things as well he's just seen me have
points of really high success before
children like I went back to college as
an older person I had both my boys
during finals weeks
I was a straight A student and it's like
then he's seen very low lows
and he's trying to figure out what he
can do well you hold on hold on you're
the daughter do anything you're the
daughter of an of someone who struggled
with addiction you're a performer
dude you could pass your bar exam and
give have birth to a kid and probably
finish the marathon you've been training
for you can perform you can't be with
because being with funny is my my dad
and his whole entire family are literal
musicians and performers and yeah
actors and that's right yes so you can
perform all day and for someone like
your husband that performance looks like
accomplishment it's not for you it's
defense yeah yes and so pretend that's
right and it drives me crazy well you've
got to stop declaring civil war with
Sadie
yeah you don't have things to undo
you've got when you used to talk about
undoing think about a knot in a rope and
you're pulling so hard to try to undo
that knot
your job is to make peace open your
hands up there's a knot in the rope
we're moving on down the road we're
moving on down
you cannot undo your the abuse that
happened as a kid
you can't unwind that
you can't unwind the things that your
dad should have freaking said to you to
you're his baby girl that he never said
and the more energy you spend trying to
unknot things that can't be undone
your your your kids your husband
everybody sees you flexing and pulling
and pulling and flexing and they don't
know what it is and so they're going to
create stories that it's their fault
yeah or that their mom's nuts
yeah
that's me because I do want to let go I
don't know how so let me tell you there
is one way and it's the most annoying
answer I could possibly give you and as
if someone who struggles in very similar
areas as you I hate to tell you this
okay
you have to have to have to come up with
a way
a language between you and your husband
that you can have some level of
vulnerability
and it's going to be something that you
have to practice
yeah whether that's a spiral notebook
that you'll share because you can't say
it out loud you're just gonna just gonna
write it down
whether that's a weekly meeting that you
have typed out that you hand him across
a table and he reads it
and it could be everything from
I wanted to hide when you came home hot
from work the other day
we've been having sex like this and I
don't like it anymore we haven't been
having sex and I miss you is it me do
you think I'm too ugly or am I too old
or whatever whatever thoughts you're
going to get you've got to figure out a
way that you can safely practice
bringing him into that conversation
and my promise to you is it's gonna feel
like somebody like you're standing naked
on the on a street corner like the whole
you're so exposed that every nerve in
your body is going to tell you cover up
cover up cover up
oh
and you have to give him the opportunity
to
peacefully engage with you and I'm gonna
tell you right now he's gonna say the
wrong stuff he's gonna say stupid stuff
oh I know we've been together long
enough I know that it's just hard for me
because we have been together for since
I was 15 years old and he's the one
person that I feel safe enough with I
don't think anybody has ever seen me
and so I think that's just been sort of
hard to navigate how to do that and he's
the only person I feel safe enough to do
that with
your second responsibility you're gonna
have is to get a couple of girlfriends
that you can begin practicing that with
too
okay
and it's gonna again feel scary
um I I had a couple of buddies about a
decade ago guys that we just drank beer
and ate nachos and hung out all the time
and watched the fights and I I actually
took the step and again these are guys
I'd known for years and so it wasn't
super weird it's like I just met
somebody
um but I told them
I've got to start getting some guys I
can be honest around
and I think my marriage is falling apart
or I think I'm not a good dad
and I think and they would give me their
bro wisdom some of it was incredible
some of it was just moronic and that's
that's fine
the important thing was not their wisdom
was not their uh insights the important
thing was I said it out loud in a group
of people that I knew were still gonna
be ride or die with me anyway
yeah right and so
that's the healing but what you have to
here here's and here's the for the
um Neuroscience nerds out there here's
what we're doing we're teaching our body
that the things that got us killed as a
kid
um are the things that are going to keep
we're teaching our body that we're safe
now
we weren't safe then
your dad was not a safe place wherever
mom happened to be was not safe the
person who sexually abused you was not
safe your husband is
yes these two women are and what we're
going to do is we're gonna practice
setting these things down
and when you feel yourself taking them
up we're just gonna write that down and
write that down and husband here's the
deal I'm gonna practice saying things to
you and honestly if you want to have him
give me a call I'd love to talk to him
because I know it's hard on his side too
I can't imagine yeah
yeah
big 50s and you and yeah have him give
me a call
um
he's gonna have to work really hard to
not take all this personally
yeah
because every time you hold a secret I
know he does I know I know every time
you hold a secret in he blames himself
for not being a husband enough or yeah
um for not being creating a safe enough
space right and so he's gonna have to
also have the courage while you're
saying your needs he's got to say his
too
yes and you're gonna have to hear those
as well right
yeah OCD and um OCD and anxiety these
things have a way of making your needs
the only needs in town and it's a lie
because one of the great the great way
paths out of this is
um
one of the great paths out is serving
other people helping other people meet
their needs and when someone starts
putting needs your first thoughts are
what about me what about me that's just
the that's just your racing mind talking
it's nonsense
great gift can be let me help you meet
your needs
um but again
I want to practice this I want you all
to practice practice figure it out
practice
um whether let's we're gonna put a
breakfast on the calendar we're gonna
put a lunch on the calendar I'm gonna
put a spiral notebook on your pillow and
you put it back on my pillow I'm just
gonna write some of these things down or
I can just tell you 15 minutes at night
before we go to bed or when we wake up
in the morning I'm gonna tell you these
things
and they're going to come in ways
there's going to be some days when
everything's wonderful there's gonna be
waves that come through and everything
is a disaster
um
but let me say this and
I hope this finds its way into your
heart a little bit
your dad wasn't well
your dad was sick your dad struggled
hard
and I think at the end your dad loved
his little girl
and as long as you live you'll never
understand the demons he was fighting
those that told him the only way to get
through today is is more pills
open your hands to that
before you go to bed tonight I want you
to write a letter in a notebook with a
pen
it's a seven-year-old Sadie
until you're sorry you've been blaming
her for so much and you've been giving
her so much to carry and it's time for
her to go play with her friends like
seven-year-olds are supposed to do and I
want you to tell that seven-year-old
Sadie that you love her the Dad loved
her
it's time for her to stop defending you
I'll be with you every step of the way
Sadie thanks for your call hang on the
line listening a copy on your past
change your future you may already have
it I'ma send you a copy of it anyway and
you and your husband can read it
together
um we can start this New Journey of
practicing
teaching our body we weren't okay then
we're okay now